tengo aquí esta matriz de 2 x 3 esta
matriz a y como ejercicio de repaso lo
que quiero hacer es calcular tanto su
espacio nulo sonoridad como su espacio
columna el sub espacio generado por las
columnas de mi matriz a así que bien
comencemos el espacio nulo la nulidad de
la matriz
es por definición el conjunto de todos
los vectores x en donde pues tengo tres
columnas así que todos los vectores x en
r3 tales que al multiplicar la matriz a
por el vector x obtengo el vector 0
noten que como como la matriz a es una
matriz de 2 x 3 el vector 0 tiene que
ser considerado en r2 así que bien otro
modo de escribir esta misma condición de
aquí
plantear la ecuación de carme copia mis
matriz a 2 - 1 - 3 - 426 ésta es la
matriz a multiplicada por por un vector
en r3 digamos x 1 x 2 x 3
y esto lo tengo que igualar con
esto lo tengo que igualar con el vector
0 de r2 así que con el vector 0 0 y
tengo que resolver este sistema bien
pues para resolver este sistema lo que
voy a hacer es poner una matriz
aumentada y mi matriz aumentada va a ser
la primera parte va a ser igual a 2 - 1
- 3 - 4 2
y la voy a aumentar con esto con el 0 0
0 0 y ahora vamos a hacer operaciones
elementales para llevarla a su forma
escalonada reducida por renglones y eso
esas operaciones no van a cambiar este
lado derecho lo cual es de esencia el
argumento de por qué la forma escalonada
reducida por renglones y la matriz
original tienen el mismo espacio nulo
pero bueno vamos allá
entonces lo primero que voy a hacer va a
ser dividir todo mi primer renglón por 2
así que aquí tendría uno menos 1 / 2 es
menos un medio menos 3 entre 2 es menos
3 medios
pero entre dos es cero y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es dividir el segundo
renglón entre cuatro así que aquí me
quedaría menos uno en los 4 24 es menos
12 entre 4 es aún medio positivo
6 entre 43 medios positivos 0 entre 4 de
nuevo es 0 así que esa de allí es la
siguiente matriz y ahora ahora lo que
voy a hacer es sumar bueno el primer
renglón lo voy a dejar tal y como están
1 - un medio menos 3 medios
y ahora voy a sumar este primer renglón
al segundo renglón entonces uno menos
más menos 10 menos un medio más un medio
es cero menos tres medios más tres
medios es cero y 0 +0 es cero
así que aquí ya tengo la forma
escalonada reducida por renglones de mi
matriz
pero y esto que me dice acerca de cómo
tienen que ser x 1 x 2 y x 3 pues el
modo más sencillo de averiguar qué es lo
que me dice es simplemente escribir esto
como el producto de la matriz uno menos
un medio
3 - 3 medios
este 0 0 0 con el vector en r 3 x 1 x 2
x 3 este producto debe ser igual
0 0 al vector 0 en r2 y de aquí pues de
aquí que puedo concluir si hago este
producto de matrices la primera entrada
del vector sería 1 por x 1 + menos un
medio por x2 más menos 3 medios por x 3
esta sería la primera entrada de este
vector es decir esto tiene que ser igual
a 0 y la segunda parte no me da una
información porque me dice 0 por algo
más 0 por algo más pero por algo es
igual a cero así que realmente no ofrece
nueva información esto de aquí esta
ecuación la puede escribir como x 1 es
igual a un medio de x 2 + 3 medios de x
y esto tiene sentido porque x1 noten que
esta de aquí ésta es una columna pivote
es una columna pivote así que
corresponde a una variable dependiente y
x2 y x 3 que no corresponden a columnas
pivote corresponden a variables libres
así que como se ve mi espacio a solución
de esto pues mi espacio y solución sería
los vectores x 1 x 2 x 3 estos vectores
que son de la forma pues vamos a
escribirlos así x2 x
por algo por algún vector más x 3 por
algún otro vector de nuevo x 2 y x 3 son
mis variables libres
ahora bien x 1 es igual a un medio por
x2 así que un medio por x2 más 3 medios
por x 3 más 3 medios por x 3 x 2 es
igual a 1 por x 20 x x 3 x 3 es igual a
0 por x 2 más 1 por x 3 así que nuestro
espacio nulo es el conjunto de vectores
de esta forma pero eso también lo puede
escribir como el espacio nulo de la
matriz a va a ser igual al sub espacio
generado
por todas las combinaciones lineales de
estos dos vectores es decir el sub
espacio generado por el vector un medio
y el vector tres medios 0 1
a veces también verán esto escrito como
el spam
d
el spam del vector un medio 10
y el vector tres medios 0 1 bien así que
este es nuestro espacio nulo que hay del
espacio columna bien pues como les decía
el espacio columna es el espacio
generado por las columnas de la matriz a
así que el espacio columna de a va a ser
igual al espacio al sub espacio generado
por los vectores
2 - 4 2 - 4 - 1 2
y menos 36 ahora aquí tengo algunos
vectores de más porque si se fijan estos
vectores no son linealmente
independientes de hecho nosotros sabemos
que si ponemos a la matriz en su forma
escalonada reducida la base del espacio
columna corresponde a los vectores que
se transforman en columnas pivote así
que esto de aquí es lo mismo que el sub
espacio generado por el vector 2 menos 4
y de hecho esto no es inesperado porque
noten que esta segunda columna es
simplemente menos un medio por la
primera y esta tercera columna es menos
tres medios por la primera columna y
solo para no dejarlo el rango de a
recuerden que el rango de una matriz se
define como la dimensión de su espacio
columna así que en este caso la
dimensión simplemente es 1 porque es el
número de vectores que me generan el
espacio columna bien ok ya que tenemos
eso pues nosotros hemos estado
trabajando con las matrices transpuestas
así que ahora quiero ver qué sucede con
estos espacios con la matriz a
transpuesta quien es la matriz a
transpuesta pues sencillamente va a ser
la matriz cuyas columnas son los
renglones de a así que déjenme los copió
sería la primera columna sería 2 - 1 - 3
y la segunda columna sería menos 4 2
esa es mi matriz a transpuesta muy bien
así que quién es el espacio nulo el
espacio nulo de la nulidad de la matriz
a transpuesta pues la matriz a
transpuesta ahora es una matriz de tres
por dos entonces el espacio nulo la
nulidad de a transpuesta va a consistir
en los vectores x en donde pues ésta es
una matriz de tres por dos tiene dos
columnas así que son los las x en ahora
en r2 tales que la matriz a transpuesta
x x es igual al vector 0 ahora en r3
porque tengo tres renglones bien
entonces como decíamos lo que voy a
hacer es transformar esta matriz o
llevar a esta matriz a su forma
escalonada reducida por renglones así
que veamos
voy a dividir el primer renglón entre
dos así que obtengo uno menos 2
luego el segundo renglón lo voy a dejar
así como está menos 12 y el tercer
renglón lo voy a dividir entre 3 - 1 y 6
entre 3 es 2 perfecto
ahora qué más se puede hacer esta matriz
pues
déjenme
me voy a dejar el primer renglón igual
uno menos dos voy a cambiar el segundo
renglón por el primero más el segundo
uno más menos uno es 0 2 más menos 2 es
cero y voy a cambiar el tercer renglón
por el tercero más el primero menos uno
más uno es cero
2 más menos 2 también es 0
así que ya tengo aquí mi matriz esta es
la forma escalonada reducida por
renglones la fehr de la matriz a
transpuesta y noten noten que tengo solo
una columna pivote así que esto de aquí
cuando hablemos del espacio columna
sabremos que es el generado por este
vector pero bueno para encontrar la
nulidad lo que voy a hacer es
simplemente escribir lo siguiente la
nulidad de a transpuesta es igual a la
nulidad de su forma escalonada reducida
por renglones así que vamos a escribir
la ecuación
1 - 20000 por un vector
x 1 x 2
eso me tiene que dar el vector cero en r
muy bien y
y de aquí que concluyó pues si resuelvo
estas ecuaciones o si expande este
producto matricial obtendría que x1
menos 2 x 2 es igual a 0 o lo que es lo
mismo x1 es igual a 2 veces x 2
de modo que
la nulidad o el espacio nulo de la
matriz transpuesta de a es igual a el
conjunto de vectores en r2 vamos a
escribir los x 1 x 2
tales que pues
necesito que x 1 x 2
obedezcan lo siguiente x1 tiene que ser
igual a dos veces x2 así que déjenme lo
pongo así voy a poner x2 aquí porque esa
es mi variable libre no corresponde a
una columna pivote así que x2 x
x 2 x 2 veces x 12 son x1 y x2 x 1 me da
x2 es esto de aquí o lo que es lo mismo
esto es el conjunto de todas las
combinaciones lineales de este vector
pero eso es simplemente el sub espacio
vectorial generado por el vector 2
perfecto y que hay del espacio columna
de a transpuesta pues eso es el espacio
el sub espacio generado por las columnas
de a transpuesta por el vector 2 - 1 - 3
y el vector menos 4 2-6 pero sólo el
primero se corresponde con una columna
pivote en la forma escalonada reducida
por renglones de la matriz a traspuesta
así que nosotros ya sabemos que el
espacio columna de a transpuesta va a
ser generado exclusivamente por el
vector
2 - 1 - 3 de hecho si se fijan la
segunda columna es simplemente la
primera columna por menos 2 y esto
geométricamente es simplemente una línea
en r3 esto genera una línea en r3 y
espero en otro vídeo poder dar una
interpretación geométrica de estos
resultados
ahora bien qué significa el espacio de
columna de a transpuesta y el espacio
nulo o la nulidad de a transpuesta pues
el espacio columna de la trans pues está
para empezar es el generado por las
columnas de a transpuesta es decir por
esa que está encerrada en amarillo en
verde y esta que está encerrada en
amarillo pero esas quiénes son pues son
precisamente son precisamente las los
renglones de la matriz a original
son precisamente estos dos y de hecho
bueno nosotros ya sabemos que estos dos
son linealmente dependientes entonces
entonces tiene sentido tiene bastante
sentido pensar
pensar en el espacio columna de a
transpuesta como el sub espacio generado
por los renglones de la matriz a
original
vamos a llamar eso el espacio fila de ar
así que esto es igual al espacio
fila o el espacio generado por las filas
los renglones de la matriz
y cómo funciona esto pues si yo tengo
una matriz
que digamos está que está conformada por
los los renglones de 1 transpuesta de 2
transpuesta eventualmente hablaremos de
la transposición de vectores pero
simplemente es pensar en los renglones
hasta bn transpuesta si estos son los
renglones de mi matriz
son los renglones de matriz y entonces
al transponer cada uno de estos se
convierte en una columna así que por eso
tiene sentido esta definición y qué hay
del espacio nulo de a transpuesta pues
comencemos por considerar a una matriz a
que va a ser una matriz de m por n
entonces su transpuesta a transpuesta
sería una matriz de n por m y el espacio
nulo de la matriz transpuesta lo
definimos mediante la ecuación la matriz
transpuesta por un vector x tiene que
ser igual al vector cero
qué pasa si trans pongo toda esta
ecuación atrás pongo de ambos lados
explicó transpuesta aquí y trans pongo
el vector cero
entonces yo sé por las propiedades de la
matriz transpuesta que esto es igual a
x transpuesto vector x transpuesto que
noten que el vector x tiene que
pertenecer a rm para que este producto
tenga sentido así que x transpuesto lo
puedo pensar como una matriz de 1 por m
por la matriz transpuesta de a pero a
eso le tengo que aplicar la transporta y
eso me tiene que dar el vector 0
transpuesto ahora bien qué es esto de
aquí
esto de aquí simplemente sería
x transpuesto por la matriz transpuesta
de la tras puesta que es la matriz
original a tiene que ser igual al vector
cero transpuesto en otras palabras de
que me lo anotó como conjuntos la
nulidad o el espacio nulo de atrás
puesto
es igual a los vectores x en rn
los vectores x en rm tales que a
transpuesta x x es igual a el vector 0
pero esto por lo que acabamos de ver es
completamente equivalente a los vectores
x en r m
tales que
x transpuesto por la matriz a es igual a
el vector 0 en r n y esto de aquí estoy
aquí ya está en términos de mi matriz
original y se llama esto se llama la
nulidad o más bien vamos a decirle el
espacio nulo el espacio nulo
izquierdo
de la matriz a de a y por qué se llama
el espacio no izquierdo porque pues
recuerden que el espacio nulo normal
está definido mediante la ecuación eran
los vectores x tales que da por x era el
vector cero así que multiplica vamos por
la derecha en este caso estamos
multiplicando por la izquierda
y perdón aquí me comí una transpuesta es
el vector cero transpuesto bien y noten
que esto es un espacio completamente
distinto es un espacio completamente
distinto al espacio nulo original el
espacio nulo izquierdo y el espacio nulo
no son la misma cosa
de hecho observemos
observemos este de aquí
con este color vamos a hacerlo este de
aquí
es mi espacio nulo de la matriz a
transpuesta así que estoy aquí es mi
espacio
espacio nulo
izquierdo
izquierdo de la matriz a que tenía el
principio de este vídeo y estoy acá es
el espacio nulo original esto representa
un plano en r3 y esto representa una
línea en r2
así que geométricamente también son
espacios muy muy distintos ni siquiera
corresponden las dimensiones en la
mayoría de los casos y que hay del
espacio columna de a transpuesta pues
dijimos que eso era el espacio fila de a
y era esto de aquí
esto de aquí es mi espacio fila de a es
el espacio columna de la matriz
transpuesta y es una línea en r3
mientras que el espacio columna de la
matriz original donde está aquí está
ahora estoy acá y era una línea en r2
así que de nuevo no tienen por qué ser
el mismo objeto ok
bueno
bueno y antes de irme antes de irme me
gustaría dejarles una última una última
lección de este vídeo si se fijan el
rango de mi matriz que era simplemente
la dimensión de ese espacio columna
coincidió coincidió con la dimensión del
espacio columna de a transpuesta con la
dimensión de su espacio fila así que
esto siempre se cumple el rango
el rango de
siempre va a ser igual a el rango
transpuesta y por qué pasa eso vamos a
estudiar un poco por qué se tiene ese
resultado pues cuando nosotros quisimos
calcular cuántos de estos vectores eran
linealmente independientes cuales
generaban lo que dijimos fue que cada
cada vector columna que fuera
linealmente independiente se iba a
corresponder con una columna pivote con
una columna pivote en la matriz
escalonada reducida ok
cuando nos preguntamos cuántas de estas
columnas son linealmente independientes
pues esa pregunta es completamente
equivalente como esta es la transporta
es equivalente a preguntarnos cuáles de
estos renglones son linealmente
independientes pero eso también lo puedo
deducir a partir de la forma escalonada
reducida por renglones de mi matriz
original porque el número de renglones
que son linealmente independientes en la
matriz original pues cada uno de ellos
se va a corresponder ya no con una
columna pivote sino con un renglón
pivote en la forma escalonada reducida
por renglones de la matriz a así que
como tenemos un renglón pivote en este
caso solo vamos a tener un renglón
linealmente independiente pero si sólo
tenemos un renglón independiente en la
matriz a entonces sólo tenemos una
columna que es linealmente independiente
en la matriz a transpuesta así que bueno
ese argumento funciona con toda
generalidad lo pueden usar para
cualquier matriz
de ese modo pueden concluir que el rango
de a es igual siempre al rango de la
matriz transpuesta